[Música]
cuando estaba en la universidad era uno
de sus científicos soberbios que estaba
autor rato evaluando a las personas de
acuerdo a su nivel intelectual me hacía
muchas ayudantías era bueno para hacer
pruebas difíciles me gustaba hacer
clases y por lo tanto cuando terminé la
carrera me fui a un par de universidades
privadas no de las mejores hacer clases
de bioquímica
cuando hacía las clases empezar cuenta
de que independiente del esfuerzo que yo
le pusiera las clases los resultados se
mantenían alrededor del 30 o 40 por
ciento de los estudiantes reprobados del
rango
esto obviamente hizo que en mi cabeza yo
pensaba que mi estudiantes eran todo
flojo tenían mala base de alguna u otra
forma era su responsabilidad esto hacía
de que yo tratara hoy quisiera
constantemente buscar otro camino
quería dejar de hacer clases en la
universidad
en ese minuto no podía hacerlo llegaba
ya un par de años y trabajar el producto
de una depresión fuerte y llegó a mí una
oportunidad de trabajar en el recién
creado instituto de neurociencia
biomédica de la universidad de chile en
el pene y era un pequeño trabajo a cargo
del área de divulgación así que lo tomé
sin embargo no pudo dejar de hacer
clases todavía
en ese minuto
con el paso del tiempo empecé a prestar
atención a lo que estaba pasando con los
estudiantes porque les iba mal a la
universidad y me di cuenta que gran
parte de los estudiantes no entendían
las preguntas de las pruebas antes de
modificar la gran parte de lo
estudiantes no tenía buena base múltiple
ante colegios técnicos entonces no
sabían nada de ciencia y la universidad
les vendió en curso una carrera
científica
con eso en mente en ese minuto hace unos
años atrás estaba el momento para el
movimiento estudiantil en chile el tema
la educación estaba muy presente en
todos los medios el tema de la gratuidad
del núcleo la calidad de la educación
entonces en ese escenario
tuve un eureka un momento de un clic que
era algo un poco obvio pero en ese
minuto me hizo mucho sentido y era que
el resultado de los estudiantes que el
estudiante les fuera mal en el ramo no
era culpa de los estudiantes como yo
pensaba antes sino que era culpa del
sistema algo que obviamente no la tienen
docente en este mundo para saber pero en
ese minuto me hizo un clic diferente hay
veces que uno entiende las cosas pero
empecé que uno entiende la cosa uno
siente algo y eso fue un punto
de cambio un punto de inflexión en el
que me di cuenta que estaba atrapado en
este que tenía que hacer algo que ya era
algo que realmente me importaba en
movida y tenía que hacerme cargo de eso
en el instituto trabajaba a codo con 7
en ese minuto el director del instituto
y buscábamos siempre referentes
internacionales inspiración para ver que
podíamos hacer con nuestra pequeña área
de divulgación que comenzó a crecer
rápidamente
teníamos un fuerte interés por el tema
artístico por buscar el arte como una
herramienta de comunicación de la
ciencia y en ese mundo nos encontramos
con un programa norteamericano
perteneciente a howard hughes medical
institute que es la segunda filantropía
más grande del mundo que financia
investigación científica entonces nos
encontramos con un con una especie de
estudio de documentales científicos para
cine muy potente muy atractivo muy
inspirador y a partir de empezar a
buscar las películas de este lugar nos
encontramos que howard hughes tenía otro
otro programa de ubicación que se
llamaba dentro de activo y éste es
también hacía documentales pues todo
comentario eran cortos y se podían
utilizar para hacer clases además estos
documentales venían con guías de trabajo
que utilizaban resultados reales de
investigaciones científicas para poder
trabajar en el aula entonces nosotros
quedamos vueltos locos con esta idea y
se nos ocurrió la brillante idea de
invitar al director de este programa a
chile que nos compliquemos lo dijo que
es inmediatamente lo invitamos a dar un
par de estarlas una charla para
estudiantes de colegio y otra charla
para la pequeña comunidad divulgadores
que existíamos en ese minuto
viendo todo lo que pasaba en este
programa obviamente no podía sacar de la
cabeza la idea de que no traemos esto
porque para nosotros va a ser meternos
en educación era algo sumamente difícil
con los recursos que teníamos para hacer
divulgación entonces no teníamos cómo
entrar en el sistema educativo teníamos
los contactos pero no teníamos los
recursos y ésta era una oportunidad
super grande entonces no pudimos evitar
posible directamente porque no
colaboramos qué podemos hacer para traer
esto acá
él dejó la puerta junta entonces yo fui
a eeuu llegue a conocer el equipo en lo
que hacían y tuvo una larga reunión para
dar de convencerlos de que chile era un
país interesante que es chileno pequeño
es un país obviamente mucho más pequeños
eeuu con un currículum único y que
podría presentar un interesante modelo
para que ellos pudiesen evaluar su
experiencia si él estaba en el proceso
de las reformas de educación el tema
político también les interesó entonces
por ahí entramos para ellos son ricos si
no les generaba una gran gran inversión
para ellos y era la primera vez que
hacían una colaboración con alguien
fuera de eeuu así que los convencimos y
así fue como comenzó nuestro programa
meta es transformador nuestras
formadoras comenzó el año 2016
invitamos el equipo de howard hughes acá
hicimos un llamado abierto a profesores
de biología que quisieran participar de
nuestros talleres nuestros talleres se
dictaban el sábado en la mañana
las actividades que nosotros decimos en
español los vídeos en español la
actividad de las alineamos el currículum
eran actividades indagatorias
entretenidas y sencillas de implementar
los talleres eran como les decía a los
ado en la mañana por lo tanto los
profesores que llegaban a los talleres
eran profesores motivados nuestros que
estaban dispuestos a usar su tiempo
libre para aprender cómo ven son
actividades relativamente experimentales
pero sin necesidad de un laboratorio y
por lo tanto son súper fáciles de hacer
implementar en cualquier colegio
bueno entonces los profesores que
llegaban solos empiezan a dar cuenta de
que habían profesores que venían de
puerto montt no se querían de concepción
que se venían el viernes en la noche en
bus para llegar el sábado la mañana un
taller estará en profesores realmente
otro nivel
cada vez se empezó a poner la voz y
seguían venía de más profesores nosotros
nuestros recursos nos permitían hacer
alrededor de 6 a 8 talleres al año de
estos 6 otros a ir al año recibíamos
alrededor de 40 profesores por taller el
30% de los profesores que eran
profesoras nuevas en cada taller durante
el primer año del programa alcanzamos
alrededor de 5000 estudiantes con las
actividades que hacíamos los profesores
estaban felices agradecían las
actividades eran actividades listas para
usar entonces no tenían que usar el
tiempo que no tienen para preparar estas
nuevas metodologías entonces para ellos
era sobre práctico y seguían viniendo y
seguían viendo lo que me llamó la
atención en un principio era como los
profesores que venían a un taller los
talleres seguían viniendo a tres primer
año el segundo año no son los profesores
que ya venían comparte talleres volvían
y contaban hoy es la actividad
modificamos esto entonces empezó a
generar de manera natural una comunidad
en la que los profesores compartían su
experiencia lo pasaban bien conversaban
se hacían amigos y se empezaban a seguir
viniendo
después de alrededor y a finales del
2017 va a interactive contrató a una
directora de evaluación y comenzaron
formalmente una etapa de evaluación de
su programa afortunadamente para
nosotros nuestro modelo era sencillo de
evaluar porque era más pequeño así que
comenzaron a hacer las evaluaciones por
acá
dentro de las evaluaciones que están en
los talleres para crear entretenidos que
ir antes
dentro de las valuaciones hicimos
encuestas focus group entrevistas
observaciones en aula los resultados
eran bastante prometedores nos empezamos
a cuenta que se repetían los mismos
comentarios de profesores de colegios
totalmente distintos los profesores que
participan 2 taller eran de colegios
particulares pagados del colegio en
subvencionado de colegio emblemáticos de
colegios públicos de distintas comunas y
de vigentes regiones de sílex
y empezamos nos cuenta que habían
patrones comunes lo primero era que para
todos los profesores lo más interesante
era lo útil que significaba tener
actividades listas para usar que venían
con guía del docente con las respuestas
con indicaciones que ellos ya observaban
que sus estudiantes empezaban a pensar
esa es la palabra que usaban veo que mis
estudiantes piensan cuando que para
nosotros era bastante emocionante y
sorprendente empezaron a haber cambios
la metodología del poco por ejemplo
estoy en una cita de una de las
profesoras que dice antes de participar
en estos talleres mis clases estaban
enfocadas en mí yo entregaba el
contenido explicaba todo en mi
presentación de a poco empecé a entregar
menos ya pedir más ahora apenas les
entregó el contenido digerido hago más
preguntas abiertas los hago trabajar en
grupo deje de ser el centro de la clase
con nosotros esto fue súper bonito súper
emocionante y kim ok los profesores
están usando el material estamos
contento ahora lo que nosotros queríamos
hacer a partir de estos resultados
nosotros logramos presentar este trabajo
en 2 concresión internacionales un simca
político en eeuu lo que también nos
reforzó un poco que esto ya bien de
hecho los resultados que nosotros
tuvimos acá el howard hughes comenzó a
implementar en su propio programa
después de bueno una de las cosas claves
de este programa para mí desde mi
perspectiva era que el programa no
estaba dirigido por nosotros o sea mi
labor en el programa era básicamente
generar el espacio para que esto
ocurriera yo traté de todas las maneras
de que los científicos no fuéramos a
enseñar a los profesores no quería esa
verticalidad que ocurre cuando nos va
el experto va a enseñar la puso entonces
el modelo que tiene es agua que usted
trabajo en ese en eeuu es a través de
embajadores ellos lo que hacen es
trabajar con un grupo profesores
motivados durante dos o tres días
intensivos les entregan las herramientas
a estos profesores para que ellos
faciliten los talleres a otros
profesores entonces de esa manera más
generando embajadores en distintas
ciudades y esto les permite propagar el
programa de manera más sencilla son eeuu
de un país gigante entonces nosotros
utilizamos la misma metodología
profesores facilitaban los talleres para
otros profesores y eso funciona perfecto
porque nosotros abiertamente les decían
los profesores que el espíritu de
nuestro programa es que sea lo más
horizontal posible es promover la
reflexión entre padres es tratar de que
un profesor que está en el taller que
viene
a 5 talleres después pueda estar
facilitando los de eso se ha dado
naturalmente tenemos un grupo de
profesores que ya están facilitando
talleres y es esta misma metodología la
que llamó la atención del ministerio de
educación y nos invitaron a hacer este
piloto para formar comunidades de
aprendizaje porque estas comunidades
surgieron de manera prácticamente
espontánea nosotros no sabíamos que iba
a pasar pero dimos el espacio para que
se ocurriera
esta oportunidad de que los profesores
pudiesen facilitar también obviamente es
algo que los profesores valoraron aquí
otra otra cita de una profesora que dice
me gusta que los profesores que
participamos en los talleres tengamos la
oportunidad de dictar talleres
esto nos empodera nosotros no podemos
enseñar en universidades no tenemos un
magíster pero aquí tenemos la
oportunidad de compartir nuestro
conocimiento y experiencia con otros
profesores esto también deja ver algo
que yo creo que todos más o menos
sabemos que los profesores se sienten un
poco maltratado y mal visto en la
sociedad no respetado entonces como
dicen ahí ellos no tienen la posibilidad
de enseñarle a otros es que no tienen un
magíster sé que no tiene un título
funcional entonces para ellos generar
estas posibilidades de desarrollo
también nos hacía sentir más empoderado
entonces después de estos análisis
nosotros como que los que amamos
obviamente supercontento estamos bien
profesor que usan el material está
funcionando
lo que pasó una de las cosas que
encontramos que realmente yo no me lo
esperaba para nada fue un ejemplo que
también se ha repetido en varios en
varios casos esto es otra cita de una
profesora que dice es bacán llegar a un
lugar donde te sirven cafecito cositas
ricas a los profes de verdad no nos
tratan así con suerte nos dan un café
que el profe lo cuiden lo quieran que lo
estimulen tú eres importante para el
país porque eso está olvidado
para mí eso fue bastante impresionante
porque
mi labor era hacer de la experiencia
experiencia agradable entonces para mí
lo natural era tener un rico café tener
como material el espacio cómodo pero
para ello significó totalmente algo
inesperado y algo nuevo todos los
profesores porque obviamente era
profesor emotiva entonces pasaban en
capacitaciones y ellos siempre nos
decían nos dan la ida scooby con un café
mayores a lo normal entonces llegara a
caer nosotros listo los atendiéramos de
esa manera nos hizo ver lo importante
que es valorar lo que los profesores
hacen y pensar que es tan importante o
sea lo importante que ellos hacen ellos
son básicamente los que van a definir el
futuro del país y yo creo que la mayoría
de nosotros no lo contempla si bien está
toda la parte formativa que es súper
relevante hay una parte que tiene que
ver con el valor que nosotros le damos
como sociedad y como individuos que es
lo que nosotros reconocemos en ello y
como valoramos lo que ellos hacen para
nosotros es demasiado importante el rol
del profesor nos preocupamos de que la
experiencia esté a ese nivel y de alguna
manera todo lo que nosotros estamos
haciendo en este programa es para los
profesores y nos hace sentir demasiado
bien ver qué
se sienten empoderados y que se sienten
respetados por nosotros por la comunidad
científica que nos ponemos a su
disposición muchas gracias
[Aplausos]